[Música]
[Aplausos]
una experiencia negativa cuando tenemos
que acudir con un médico vivimos en una
ciudad privilegiada en la que tenemos
los mejores hospitales los mejores
equipos los más modernos pero de alguna
manera escuchamos frecuentemente
comentarios de experiencias negativas
por sentir que no los trataran como un
ser humano cuando acuden a una consulta
hemos pasado de una medicina en la que
se acompañaba mucho pero se curaba poco
a otra en la que tenemos una cura para
prácticamente cualquier cosa pero
pareciera que el enfermo y su enfermedad
son enemigos del médico
pensemos por un momento cuántos de
nuestros hospitales cuentan con una
ludoteca un área especial para que
nuestros niños puedan seguir aprendiendo
tengan acceso a juguetes oa poder ver
una película mientras están internados y
que es parte de los derechos
fundamentales de los niños
hospitalizados que incluso está
declarado en una carta desde 1986
más de 30 años han pasado y nuestros
niños siguen sin poder ejercer este
derecho cuántos de nuestros hospitales
cuentan con un equipo de tanatólogos
profesionales que estén listos ahí en el
caso de tener que transmitir una mala
noticia en el caso de un fallecimiento o
por ejemplo como con la experiencia que
vivimos el año pasado con el temblor de
la ciudad de mexico y que pueda ayudar
en esos casos de crisis
es urgente un cambio en el paradigma de
cómo se trabaja y aprende en el sistema
de medicina ver al ser humano no solo en
su cuestión biológica o física sino
verlo de una manera integral donde
también tomemos en cuenta la cuestión
social biológica y espiritual
además de esto la medicina actual tiene
varias áreas oportunidad la primera es
que cada vez el acto médico es más breve
sin importar si estamos en un médico
público o privado
nos damos cuenta de que muchas veces el
tiempo diseñado para una consulta no es
mayor a 15 minutos no sé qué piensen
ustedes pero para mí 15 minutos es muy
poco tiempo para poder interrogar sobre
las cuatro esferas del ser humano y si
además de eso le agregamos que hay
estudios que nos dicen que los médicos
interrumpimos a nuestros pacientes en
promedio cada 17 segundos esto quiere
decir que en realidad ellos tienen muy
poca oportunidad de expresar la ansiedad
la angustia la desesperanza que están
sintiendo con su enfermedad
otra área de oportunidades que cada vez
se solicitan más exámenes y se revisan
menos a los pacientes antes la medicina
era considerado un arte donde tenías que
usar tus cinco sentidos tenías que saber
exactamente qué parte del abdomen palpar
para poder dar un diagnóstico donde
colocar tu estetoscopio para poder saber
qué patología cardíaca tenía tu paciente
que observar específicamente en unas
amígdalas que están dolorosas y
seguramente les ha pasado a ustedes que
muchas veces el médico ni siquiera te ha
revisado y ya te dio una lista
interminable de exámenes de laboratorio
que hay que solicitar
y esto se vive como una perdida para
nuestros pacientes
otra área de oportunidad es que la
relación médico-paciente cada vez es más
impersonal antes un mismo médico atendía
a toda la familia incluso diferentes
generaciones de una misma familia hoy
son pocos los médicos que hacen esto o
que se toman el tiempo de realizar un
familia grama
esto es conocer no sólo los antecedentes
médicos de la familia sino los tipos de
relaciones los oficios y si lo
hiciéramos nos diéramos cuenta de
patrones que se repiten dentro de una
familia y que son muy importantes porque
también tienen que ver con cómo vive su
enfermedad
nuestras hospitales se han convertido en
estructuras muy deshumanizadas tenemos
hospitales diseñados por arquitectos
reconocidos internacionalmente que son
hermosos por fuera pero que al entrar
nos topamos con espacios poco iluminados
fríos con muebles incómodos y de qué nos
sirve entonces una inversión millonaria
si no podemos calmar el cansancio que
siente él
el paciente perdón a su familia
la última área de oportunidad es que se
ha dejado a un lado las necesidades
emocionales de los pacientes nos fijamos
solamente en la cuestión física de ellos
olvidamos la ansiedad y la angustia que
ellos están viviendo durante años
entonces nos hemos dedicado a conocer
mejor el cuerpo humano olvidando áreas
que son muy importantes en este nuevo
modelo o en este nuevo paradigma será
importantísimo también incluir a la
familia pues la familia funciona como un
sistema y cuando una de sus partes
enferma o se descompone todo el sistema
tiene que acomodarse o adaptarse para
poder seguir funcionando
les confieso que cuando yo estudié
medicina no aprendimos nada sobre estos
temas
quedamos en nuestras prácticas clínicas
sin saber ni siquiera a cómo dar una
mala noticia recuerdo la primera vez que
me pidieron decirle a alguien que su
familiar había muerto de esto hace ya
más de 15 años y es como si todavía
pudiera sentir la ansiedad la
taquicardia el nudo en la garganta el
temblor en las manos el miedo de tener
que decir esto sin tener los recursos
necesarios la explicación que me dieron
de esta indicación fue pues en algún
momento tienes que aprender a hacerlo y
jamás olvidaré la cara de esas personas
cuando yo les dije que su mamá había
fallecido
recuerdo haberlo hecho con todo el
corazón con las mejores intenciones pero
estoy segura que pudo haberlo hecho de
mejor manera
después me puse a estudiar una maestría
de tanatología y al terminar le presenté
a diferentes hospitales de la localidad
un proyecto que incluía consejería
tanatológica acompañamiento para los
pacientes capacitación para el personal
algo que para mí tenía tanta
trascendencia que era imposible que se
negaran la sorpresa fue que así fue me
dijeron que no había presupuesto que no
había un área física que no había
personales que se pudieran dedicar a eso
entonces tuve que cambiar la manera de
ver cómo cambiar las cosas y pensé que
la humanización de la medicina podía
empezar desde las aulas desde que el
médico se estaba formando antes de que
el cansancio o el conocer otras personas
pudiera nublar su visión acerca de la
importancia de estos temas o antes de
que ellos tuvieran que vivir una
experiencia como la que yo viví
hoy les quiero decir con el corazón
lleno de orgullo y alegría que ya hay
una universidad aquí que decidió agregar
tanatología a su plan de estudios y les
quiero presentar a la primera generación
de médicos que ya se está preparando en
estos temas
sería difícil poderles expresar en
palabras el entusiasmo que ellos están
enseñando en aprender sobre estos temas
eso quiere decir que el cambio ya está
aquí y no faltará mucho para verse
reflejado en nuestros hospitales en
nuestros consultorios
a ellos siempre les digo que nuestros
hospitales ya están llenos de personas
sumamente estudiadas y capacitadas pero
que nos falta recordar que al ejercer la
medicina es un compromiso para toda la
vida un compromiso de ayuda de auxilio
al que más lo necesita
la diferencia entre curar y sanar es que
curar involucra sólo el aspecto físico
de la persona curar sería solo ver que
nuestros síntomas desaparecer sanar es
algo mucho más profundo puede sanar
involucra las emociones la mente lo que
es el ser
para ti para mí y para los que vienen en
camino el cambio en la manera de curar
ya está cerca pero tomemos conciencia
también de que todos nosotros tenemos
los recursos para buscar diferentes
maneras de sanar lo que quizá hemos
olvidado por no poderlo ver por no
poderlo medir que son nuestras emociones
y nuestro corazón muchas gracias
[Música]